les temps sont difficiles pour mélanie
du m maman de trois enfants est
couturière depuis plus de 25 ans des
petites entreprises on n'a pas les reins
assez solides surtout dans cette période
note d'année avec les vendre son pôle
eaux l'argent rentre pas mais il ya
peut-être de l'espoir elle pourrait
bientôt confectionner des vêtements pour
le personnel hospitalier
nous on travaille avec nos mains on est
en rupture faict enquête à rien faire à
attendre n'a pas trop savoir mais pour
mieux aider des centaines de couturières
sont prêtes à soutenir le gouvernement
pour contrer la pénurie d'accessoires et
vêtements médicaux camille goyette
gingras qui gère une coopérative a
demandé aux couturières du québec de se
mobiliser sur les réseaux sociaux
on pensait rassemblé 30 couturière
finalement maintenant là alors où on se
parle on et 1800 ça continue d'augmenter
c'est vraiment extraordinaire là et
elles sont prêtes à faire leur part
soumises blues il ya des métiers aussi
qui m'ont contacté qui m'ont dit qu'ils
avaient des besoins pour des scrabble
est une forme ou est beau c'est à des
choses relativement simples qui peuvent
être et qui vont être nettoyées de tout
façon à tous les jours les pièces seront
prêts coupé est envoyé directement chez
les couturières avec un modèle
d'assemblage une fois qu'ils ont
terminée ils vont nous rappeler dire
j'ai fini que l'on va chercher le
matériel plan on va regarder comment ça
sur le pour le pick up du matériel pour
qu'il soit transmis de façon sécuritaire
aux services de santé
on est chanceux d'avoir une main
d'oeuvre qualifiée c'est l'organisme la
grappe qui représente 250 entreprises de
l'industrie de la mode au québec qui
coordonne le déploiement des ressources
nous la grappe un mode qu'on va faire
c'est de les mettre en contact avec les
différents organismes et acteurs de
l'industrie pour pouvoir bien utiliser
leurs capacités tout ce qu'on veut
essentiellement l'on veut donner un coup
de main puis par le faire mais moi je
vais dès les couturières qui sont à la
maison ce moment qu'ils savent pas
comment ils vont se rendre
financièrement au bout tout ce qui
manque ce sont les contrats les
couturières espère avoir des nouvelles
rapidement du gouvernement ici marie
michel lauzon radio-canada à montréal